we want to tell you this this show is
learning tonight this is a Fox News
Alert from well-informed sources in the
administration that White House chief of
staff General John Kelly may be
preparing to leave his job likely very
soon now Kelly is an honorable and
capable man one of the most impressive
effort to hold that post and many will
be sad to see him go me included the
question is who replaces him now
apparently there are several contenders
tonight those would include OMB director
Mick Mulvaney Mulvaney is a wiz on
budget matters does he agree with the
president's core promises on immigration
though can he represent the interests of
trumps voters on border enforcement that
is not a small thing it ought to be an
absolute requirement for that job White
House chief of staff also on the list we
are hearing is former aide hope Hicks
now hope Hicks is young and generally
pressure high relatively few outside of
Washington they even heard her speak but
in a White House riven by factionalism
and leaking Hicks is one of the very few
people in Washington maybe very few
people on the planet who has the
reflexive trust of the president he
could use more people like that for sure
at a time like this we'll keep you
posted as to what we hear on that